yeah yeah sure sure sure sure do how ins
they said we find they said okay I'm
fine I'm fine I'm fine
hey what's going on everybody four first
we feast I'm Sean Evans and you're
watching hot ones it's the show with hot
questions and even had her winks and
today we're joined by Justin Timberlake
is one of the century's most prolific
and successful singer songwriters with
more than 32 million albums sold ten
Grammy Award wins four Emmys and not to
be outdone you can catch him his branch
in trolls world tour which is set to
theaters on April 17th Justin Timberlake
welcome to the show thank you
I know that you're a Memphis boy but
have you ever made the trip to Nashville
for that hot chick in it like Prince's
or Hattie B's Hattie B's yeah I've never
gone the whole the whole ride I'm too
afraid I won't make it home in time well
buckle up your seat belt Justin
Timberlake cuz we're about to go stare
at a restroom close by I'm serious
[Music]
I feel like I should have worn a diaper
I'm not gonna lie
okay where are we starting right up down
here there yeah okay all right
that's actually quite enjoyable that's
what we started off I feel like that's
the only time I'm gonna say that today
so as you mentioned up top you returned
to troll town later this month not only
got your role as branch but also as the
soundtracks executive music producer
what are some of the unique challenges
and writing a song that's for a specific
scene and trolls but then can also live
by itself totally independently divorced
from the film as a hit it is challenging
because you have to be specific but also
ambiguous you always get like a specific
criteria what they're sort of going for
and then you kind of pick a vibe that's
what we did the first time I can't stop
the feeling so it's been really cool to
almost go on a little bit of a like
history Trek with the music someone
playing hide and seek in the rafters
so inside baseball we're in like the
voices soundstage
oh you know so I don't know like maybe
like setting up like the whole voice
stage over there I feel like that's a
ghost up there saying don't go any
further
that's already hot to me bro that's
party a kick earlier than you were
expecting it yeah earlier a little bit
for me to even you know I yeah this is a
hot two for us really yeah we're ten
seasons in this does feel like the
hottest to we've I mean I don't know how
you do that how do you do this every
well every time I'm I feel like I'm an
opportunist right and so when I first
started you know you always have you
have this idea but who knows if that
idea is ever gonna get off the ground I
keep going well I'm doing that but
that's why I keep going you know you get
another opportunity you get another
opportunity and then now Here I am
sitting in front of Justin Timberlake
shooting the [ __ ] over wings you know
what I mean what am I supposed to do run
away from that bro alright sold just
keep this train going keep it going
so it's clear that you ride hard for
Memphis it's the city that's shaped and
inspired you your whole career for sure
what's a more essential Memphis dining
experience is it the burger and dyers or
is it the fried chicken at Gus's I love
Gus's chicken but there was a they may
be out of business now but there was a
place that me and my friends used to go
to that was out of town and off the
highway and it was called the store on
the hill and they used to smoke like a
whole pork shoulder every day and that
was the spot what's the difference
between a great Elvis impersonator and a
mediocre Elvis impersonator you cut the
lip lip like a and there's like a husky
but there's always use of a broad oh
there's like a vibrato that comes with a
good Elvis so when you hear there's
different Elvis's - the most popular
Elvis to impersonate is probably the
Vegas Elvis which is all like kung fu
kicks and like air guitar very late
stage yes I mean Eddie Murphy always had
my favorite Oh show crazy I was like
we're going win anyone am i dating
myself right now you're all like 14 and
then finally let's say I'm loading up a
playlist right for a road trip to grind
City what are three essential
non-negotiable albums that have to be on
it
oh [ __ ] you got something Otis or ow
something I'll green or my nose is
already running when I think in Memphis
I think of Stax I mean obviously you
think of Elvis so I guess you'd have to
have some sort of Elvis greatest hits a
three 6 mafia album not to get into a
debate sort of the originators of
triplet trap music ha how many of I
named at least five or six have I okay
all right yeah then there you go
[Music]
Fiji Ryder
so one of the great genres of youtube
video is Timbaland playing beats for
artists for the first time then reacting
to him in a very excited way do you
remember how he reacted playing you cry
me a river the first time the crazy
thing about cry me a river was he
beatbox at first I came into the studio
and I was uh
less than thrilled and he I think he saw
my mood and he just started like he just
started like don't don't don't
Tamara you started doing this like crazy
there's first time I ever beat box with
chicken in my mouth I'm actually shocked
that I got that out we're hyped that we
got the exclusive exclusive chicken
beside Sheik beatbox we're working with
Scott Storch as well and Scott laid the
roads and the next thing I know like I
kind of like blacked out I was just off
to the races writing the song four hours
later I was like written and recorded
and then it was what we started working
on off the post-production
[Music]
little bit of a sneak attack yeah I
think it's a it's like a throat scratch
with this one you know you're all
hitting in different ways this is the
first sort of like throat scratch yeah
yeah it was kind of like it started off
like hey how's it going and then it was
that guy at the party who like two beers
in he's leaning on people for no reason
and then he's like shouting at people an
hour later I know and I feel like
somewhere like that's where we're headed
yes we're headed towards like a break a
chair over somebody's head kind of drunk
yeah
followed by like like like full-on like
tears
yeah and breakdown you don't even know
man that's what we're headed right
that's what we're gonna get cool cool
great I'm glad I'm glad we know so your
career expands so many facets of the
entertainment industry but out of
curiosity where does creating your own
hype be certified Air Jordan fall on
your list of career accomplishment
probably very very high that holds a
high space of real estate there was a
moment where tinker and the brand we're
going to make a new shoe for me for it
to work and sneak in sneak attack here
it comes
and our first meeting tinkers kind of
sitting there we're talking about
inspiration where you headed who are
your idols and he starts from me ethos
there and then they came back six months
later and that's when we started talking
about an actual sneaker there's probably
two or three other ones that we've
talked about some sketches involve
reworking or sort of innovating
[Music]
starting to get like a dizzy vibe does
that like did you ever consider that
this whole thing is like a health hazard
I always am like waiting because now we
are like ten seasons in like 200
episodes and I am waiting like I'm like
the thing that takes it down right is
gonna be like a let's have good legal do
you have like a good thing going we put
a lot of us feel hey we put a lot of
trust and Randy then he seems like a
decent guy when I talked to UM guy I
don't think we've really challenged him
with anything right right alright well
maybe it's today is it this I mean this
is it this is a health hazard I mean
let's not let's be real about this but
voluntary you know that's what we can
Lena no totally totally I would sign
anything yet alright just me every crane
segment on our show called explain that
grammar we do a deep dive on our guests
Instagram pull interesting pictures that
need more context and today Justin we
have a basketball theme for you so we'll
show you the picture you just tell us
the bigger story and then first up it's
you courtside with JJ Watt actually did
Fallon last week and JJ Watt was on oh
and you dated Hollins yeah that's right
that's right
look at you keeping up with it yeah well
Fallon won't he like sends me his no I'm
kidding he doesn't do that funny enough
we were at dinner together two nights
later and he said that you guys did
Holland and then I was I was come on Wow
yeah the universe you're uh it's a
circle you're part of the crew man
you're part of the coop but JJ said that
you choreographed touchdown dance for
him and then he did it on the show I
mean somebody can grab it and show me
the dance then then I'll let you know if
I did it or not check the tape make sure
that you cosign it on an artistic level
alright next up this is kind of surreal
you had like on real life yeah white men
can't jump moment with was exactly what
that is so I was shooting a comedy in
New York with Mila Kunis called friends
with benefits and witty plays my boss
was like we have to
like a basketball scene in the movie
because of just how woody harrelson we
have to have like a white men can't jump
moment and he has to dunk the ball so
that's where that came from
have you ever met woody no never I want
him in the show side to everything the
myth he was up to everything you want
Woody Harrelson to be he's a he's a
full-on rock star
alright so here you are getting beat up
by Usher and then I'm not sure if you're
aware of this or not but the ringer
actually named you one of the greatest
all-time NBA all-star Celebrity game
players oh really
the the spice of that one just got went
through and up and is behind my right
eye so what's the question again do you
have like a most notable athletic
achievement in all of those games like
oh oh oh hidden a jumper on Kenny Smith
there's actual there's footage of it and
and and Chuck won't let him live it down
and it's not really that big a deal cuz
he basically just saw me I was like
there's no way this kid can hit a jumper
and I did and I don't think I scored for
the rest of the game cuz he basically
just deed me up the rest of the game
okay I feel like this is the this is a
turning point right up yeah we're in the
back and this is like we only scored 10
points each in the first half and now we
got to go like pull Pat mahomes with
this [ __ ] yup okay
all right comeback time alright what is
this one
tie-dye green chile over here right I
feel like this is gonna I feel like this
is
I feel like this is that is where the
health hazard part kicks in
Oh God so your work behind the scenes
and music goes well beyond this film you
obviously have a list of writing credits
a mile long from writing for Rihanna and
Reba McEntire to doing drums and
keyboard for Charlie Wilson how's that
uh the hot tie and then you hear a
[ __ ] where you just said sorry go
back what do you think would fascinate
people about how some of their favorite
music is made like can you unpackage the
camps thing we're like some of the best
producers and top writers in the
industry they will descend on one
location for weeks crafts music that can
sometimes you know each track be
$100,000 before an artist even walks
into the studio I think the person that
are probably most famously worked with
is probably Tim Berlin and their
Neptunes
when we were doing my second record
future sex love sounds
Nate was working on the keyboards with
this new arpeggiated synthesizer you
know plug-in and all I heard was an
hour's I don't know what that is but at
that we have whatever that is we have to
work on that now the first song we did
was what Goes Around the second song we
did was my love and then the third song
we ended up doing was sexy back you know
you get in you get into certain vibes
for a week or so and you just got a I
don't know you got to follow it yeah it
could be something as loose as like you
bangin on buckets I'm totally good like
the Yonsei part and partition where
you're just like banging on buckets Wow
Wow I also nard wash it that was good
yes that's how that came about right and
not what Beyonce's like freestyling
while you're banging on top so I'm
banging on buckets and
dream came in and he started like
freestyle and a melody to it and so then
we just started messing with it that way
that felt like a camp to me because you
were just kind of everyone was just
spitting ideas back and forth like
Miguel came in I had to leave town for a
second and Miguel came in and worked on
this ballad and wrote these verses and
then I came back in and wrote a hook to
it and that was a fun time it was a
really fun time speaking of fun times
Justin okay are you ready - yeah I'm
ready
the stargaze are here at number seven a
stargazer okay
like you'll see stars when you eat this
[ __ ] only one way to find out okay I'm
gonna go for a rose sauce heavy part of
this way
I've gettin real so you hosted Saturday
of 5go pressors there's both peppers in
that and they come through yeah
they don't go yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
no this is a testing this is like the
quick this is like the quick 15 set like
we're getting I know what's happening
right now and I can't stop it you know
what I mean like I know it's about to
happen to me right now so get your memes
ready
so you've hosted Saturday Night Live
five times including twice doing social
duties who do you think does the best
Justin Timberlake impression is it
Fallon
Matt Damon or Andrew Garfield ooh I'm
gonna I'm gonna go with I'm gonna go
with the Andrew Garfield his head the
most nuance he caught some things that
happened to me that are uncontrollable
where he sort of bust me up and my face
starts to contort a little like it's
probably gonna do in the next three
wings and then I read that you were
really the one who stood by dick in the
box you know even when the indie
Sandberg even when everybody else around
it was like a little weary about it I
heard that you were the one who was who
stood by his conviction that's true made
that happen that's true well here's the
the story that people may not know about
Dean and be as I like to call it is uh
here comes the snap bro
[Music]
uh-oh that's serious that's serious we
have three more to go
yeah yeah yeah sure sure sure sure do
how ins they said we find they said okay
I'm fine I'm fine I'm fine I'm fine
you look fine um um the thing people
don't know about the thing people don't
know about Deana B is Lauren was like
you know we have to get you in every
island guys there's song and dance and
it's comedy and that's when I first met
Andy and we we hit it off immediately so
Wednesday comes around and we come up
with nothing
so uh sorry I will arrive at the point
this goes forever got me crazy right now
okay so we were like what if we came up
with like a duo of guys who are still
stuck in a time and a certain style with
like the silk suits and the you know
that herringbone chains and well and
meticulously sculpted facial hair am i
describing in sync this is weird I just
realized that we took so much from those
groups holy [ __ ] Wow hot ones finally
your ma says what if we do the old like
popcorn at the movies prank and I was
like what you guys you know you dick in
the popcorn and I was like that sounds
super creepy bro to which we then said
yeah that's totally appropriate for two
guys that are completely misled about
what's appropriate right Friday we shoot
all day and we don't get done until like
3:00 a.m. on Saturday and then the FCC
shows up like you kiss a dick on the air
oh right but if you just bleep it would
we be fine and she said yeah if you
bleep it out then then it's fine and I
think the irony of that is I think the
funnier version is the bleeped over
sometimes it works out though right
no and but yeah I believe that that that
I that that idea would not have been
seen all the way through if
the bigwigs would have known what we
were doing
this one's heavily coated I thought I'm
gonna go really back after this
I noticed that this is the first one you
haven't asked a question right as I've
dug in we're waiting for I'm
anticipating yeah yeah
you're just making sure everything's
okay before I just uh move on it's not
okay I'm gonna be on haha not okay it
hits a little different this one yeah
she hits different what's your handicap
these days that number seems to improve
with every design I just saw my antique
a bro that number seems to improve with
every Golf Digest holy [ __ ] what is
happening right now
ah I don't know what it is right now I
don't know why anything is right now but
you walking it off give me a second it's
a great bomber by the way Joseph thank
you
huh
[Music]
oh man
that's emotional I was gonna go to
premiere tonight to support my wife but
I think she's gonna have to support me
now this is real I don't know what's
happening to my equilibrium right now
all over the place yeah yeah yeah I feel
like I feel like I've been poisoned
because I have is there cyanide in this
oh man
yeah I know I've seen people when they
go like don't like the people who have
done this before they're like don't lick
your lips and this did it canary I don't
know what they mean now I regret I
regret it I'll play to gusta which was
pretty crazy I got to play with Justin
Rose I also got to play with Clint
Eastwood have you ever had the pimento
cheese sandwich at a gust I have
overrated or undergone oh no it's it's
it's you gotta hit it yeah another
famous food item Olympic Club they do
their hot dogs on hamburger buns that's
really good I'm glad to see you're
having some sort of reaction
listen I'm human I'm human Justin yeah
you I see you a day edit the [ __ ] out of
you because you looked a fly on that
[ __ ] bro
why is this like a thing why are we why
you don't have to no no no no no no no
we've made it this far I'm not gonna run
like 21 miles of the marathon okay
respect all right I'm gonna have IBS for
like a month but but pretty kick-ass
YouTube video to show but uh well we'll
see won't we
something there's gonna be a lot of ass
real soon all right all right okay okay
okay what you hot ones they said it'll
be fun they said are you having a good
time I am not gonna lie I am so Marilyn
hold on
sure hold on sure how do they do that
the time yeah yeah right that's like oh
that's like a willy wonka it's a trick
hot sauce thing they log you into that
sense of false security and then like
Everlasting Gobstopper where the hot
sauce comes in so Marilyn Manson once
said that people underestimate how
badass you are
and that under Maryland's awesome and
that you can have a dark side do you
feel like Marilyn Manson understands you
in a way that few others do the first
time I ever met Marilyn you came out to
me at a party so much tapped me on my
shoulder I turn around I was like uh uh
hey what's up I was 21
and he goes looking down at me and he
says I think your debut album is the
most genius thing that's come out in the
last five years I was like wow thank you
bro that means a lot I was like I think
you're [ __ ] genius yourself
Danny goes please don't tell anyone I
told you that and he walked up but no
years later like Marilyn and I we kicked
a little bit I love Marilyn he's he's a
rad rad human alright just until it's
happening it's happening it's happening
you just gone Widowmaker Marilyn Manson
last last AB
[Music]
okay I'm gonna go I'm gonna hit it I'm
gonna hit it
whoa you're not joking it's uh but I
mean how many times do you do hot ones
until you do it again right exactly
can we count on your returning Justin
you know what I can get back to me on
that one I'm gonna go with a strong yes
I'll come back you're her to here
that's nice to hear um um I'd come back
all right Cheers
you didn't go I'm gonna go you know no
no no it's all the time so it's like I
can't have no wasn't a challenge I know
but I can't have you doing that okay
doing that to me over here I'm gonna
regret this right uh-huh
we all fall okay okay all right okay
okay hey let's make some noise thank you
[Applause]
yeah okay
[Music]
all right Justin here we are at the top
of spice Mountain one last hurdle to
clear and you know your friend jay-z he
loves to dive into one of the most
classic of all fan debates which is
ranking his album simcha you've won ten
Grammys dozens of top-ten hits a
worldwide fan base that's always craving
the next thing you're still kind of say
all that so from your unique perspective
right now with your brain as very money
right now scrambled uh-huh how would you
rank your own discography oh okay okay
that's hard to do I understand for a lot
of different reasons one I came and see
you right now
- you try to do something different
every time you put a record out explore
different sound a different sauce if you
will justify was my debut coming out of
a boy group want to explore my own sound
it's coming it's coming now um future
sex love sounds that album happened
because I wanted so badly to make an R&B
album with justified and I was young and
naive and got my fall open my feelings
because it was under the pop album
category and my tongue is numb and I'm
gonna go write that song right now my
tongue is numb and so I decided well if
I'm pop and I can do whatever I want
so that's not you can future sex love
sounds and then 20 21 and Sue was really
like an exploration of how expansive can
we make the music in the men of the
woods being my most familial album a lot
of people don't know this but my son's
name Silas means of the forest or of the
woods so it more or less is a dedication
to him but I don't know I guess I would
say future sex
maybe then justified 2021 man the woods
and then 20 22 well thank you for
sharing those very generous of you
Justin and I at
you you legend all the way down the
spicy winged gauntlet and just a little
sweat on the forehead you look great
perhaps better now no lattes here no
water and now there's nothing left to do
but roll out the red carpet for you my
friend this camera this camera this
camera let the people know what you have
going on in your life you guys don't let
this discomfort be in vain support my
family and go out see trolls world tour
you're gonna love it but it's been worth
it you're a great guy model American and
we did it did it get it I have a buddy
who's like hot sauce aficionado like he
brings like a truffle hot sauce and he
brings like a crazy hot like he does
like it means a ghost pepper hot sauce
smells like bro I'm doing hot ones and
he was like what is life let's go
[Laughter]
that was fun that was fun I don't know
what I said
but I would do it again this is the part
where I have to remind people be careful
around your eyes your eyes
careful run jump run your eyes careful
around your eyes careful run your eyes
your eyes Korda [ __ ] yeah
careful around your eyes careful around
your eyes careful around your eyes
careful around your eyes careful run
your eyes careful around your eyes just
be careful around your eyes Oh God
careful around your eyes careful with
the eyes yeah be careful with the with
the I'm ready might be hard for you to
even touch your eye like you'd be wanted
tiny little coat nails is making strong
life decisions can't touch her faces so
that's a good point to bring up
thoroughly wash there
you
[Music]